(orchestral music)
- Very often people
think it's gonna be funny
and then they realize it's not really.
We really do music, it's not impossible
to make music with vegetables.
(orchestral music continues)
(audience applause)
(pleasant music)
My name is Susanna Gartmayer and I'm
a member of the Vegetable Orchestra.
The orchestra exists since 18 years now.
The first instrument was the tomato
because you can do sound with tomatoes
but it will be messy, for sure.
We go shopping on the market first.
We choose all the vegetables there.
We have three kinds of instruments.
One is the ready-made, you can just
buy it at the market and play it.
It's like the pepper, it's called, no?
(squeaking of peppers)
It's ready already.
And then there’re just
simple instruments like
with one cut or some cuts.
(flapping of eggplants)
We get it like that, then
with the more complex
instruments we have some that
work like normal instruments.
You know, the pumpkin is the bass drum
and the sound of the
pumpkin is really important.
- Good.
- After shopping we go to the venue
and start to build instruments.
(drills whirring)
All in all, it takes two
to three hours to build all
the instruments for everybody.
And then we start with the sound check.
(whistle blowing)
And since we have new
instruments each time, we have to have
a very long sound check.
(whistling of vegetables)
(audience applause)
(tribal and orchestral-like music plays)
We have a lot of different
musical influences in the orchestra.
Since we're really many people,
everybody's interested
in different things.
We make a soup during the building process
of the vegetable instruments with the
remaining vegetables and we serve it
to the audience after the concert.
And it's also after hearing and seeing us
and smelling the vegetables, which will be
intense in there because
it's so small, this theater.
And then you can also eat it.
You never get it out of your head anymore
if you're in the orchestra to
look vegetables in another way.
(audience applause)
(high pitched musical tone)